TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
and welcome to another
episode of "The Developer
Show," a special, on the ground
at Google I/O 2016 edition.
In this episode, we're going
to talk about Android Pay.
All right, Hana.
Tell me about Android Pay.
HANA CHANG: Android Pay
is a really easy way
to use your phone to
actually pay for things.
You don't need cash.
You don't need to fumble around
in your purse for your wallet.
All you need is your phone.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I
like the simplicity
of Android Pay, just sort
of reducing complexity
throughout my day,
something I really enjoy.
And all I have to
do is tap my phone.
HANA CHANG: Easy as that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
at Google I/O 2016,
we had some announcements
around Android Pay.
What were they?
HANA CHANG: We had a couple
of really great announcements.
One of them is that
Android Pay is an easy way
to pay in InstaMaps, which is
also a product we announced
at Google I/O. We are also
doing a partnership with Bank
of America, where you don't
actually need your debit
card to get cash out.
You can simply tap your phone
and it acts as your debit card.
The other thing is that
we're bringing easy payments
to the web.
So right now, it's only
an in-app experience.
We actually want that
to be everywhere,
so we have a new
product payment request
where Android Pay will be an
easy way to pay on the web.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
HANA CHANG: We're also live in
our first international market,
which you hear cheers
around the world, in the UK.
So you can now use Android Pay
to pay in places like Starbucks
and also riding the Tube, which
is different from the subway.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
HANA CHANG: Which I've learned.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So I've heard.
Well, should we use
this opportunity
as an excuse to get
some schwag from I/O?
HANA CHANG: Always.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's do it.
Can we have these two shirts?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Sure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Great.
There we go.
That was great.
HANA CHANG: Easy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
So here's our cool shirts.
Thank you for showing
me Android Pay.
HANA CHANG: Anytime.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]